Elles le font, car nous, en tant que lecteurs,
nous sommes particulièrement doués pour remplir les vides.
En fait, en dessin, il y a ce concept d'espace négatif.
Au lieu de dessiner l'objet réel,
on dessine l'espace qui l'entoure.
De fait, les bols sont vides dans ce dessin.
Mais l'encre noire incite votre cerveau à imaginer la nourriture dans l'espace vide.
Ce qu'on voit ici, ce n'est pas un hibou en vol.
On voit en réalité deux piles classiques
posées sur un dessin absurde,
et j'anime la scène en bougeant ma lampe de bureau de haut en bas.
(Rires)
L'image n'existe que dans notre cerveau.
De combien d'informations avons-nous besoin pour déclencher une telle image ?
En tant qu'artiste, je cherche à minimiser leur usage.
J'essaie d'atteindre un niveau de simplicité
tel que si on enlève un seul élément,
le concept entier s'effondre.
Voilà pourquoi, en tant qu'artiste, l'abstraction est mon outil préféré.
J’ai développé un système que j'ai nommé « abstractomètre ».
Ça fonctionne comme ceci :
vous prenez n'importe quel symbole, un cœur avec une flèche, par exemple,
le symbole de l'amour pour la plupart d'entre nous.
Comme je suis un artiste, je peux choisir de le dessiner
avec n'importe quel degré de réalisme ou d'abstraction.
Si mon dessin est trop réaliste, c'est dégoûtant.
(Rires)
Mais si je pousse mon dessin trop loin dans l'abstraction,
plus personne ne le reconnaît.
Donc je dois trouver l'endroit parfait sur mon échelle,
dans ce cas-ci, c'est au milieu.
Maintenant qu'on a réduit l'image à une forme plus simple,
une large variété de connexions nouvelles s'ouvrent à nous.
Ça ouvre de toutes nouvelles perspectives à la narration.
(Rires)
Et donc, ce que j'aime faire,
c'est associer des images issues d'endroits culturellement éloignés.
Avec des références plus audacieuses --
(Rire)
je m'amuse encore plus.
Mais bien sûr, je sais que tôt ou tard ça va devenir trop occulte,
et je vais perdre quelques-uns d'entre vous.
Pour un dessinateur, c'est donc absolument essentiel d'avoir une bonne compréhension
du vocabulaire visuel et culturel de son audience.
Avec cette image, un commentaire sur les Jeux Olympiques d'Athènes,
je fais le pari que le lecteur du « New Yorker »
a des connaissances rudimentaires en art grec.
Si ce n'est pas le cas, l'image ne fait pas sens.
Si c'est le cas, vous apprécierez le dessin jusqu'au moindre petit détail,
le motif des canettes de bière dans le bas du vase, par exemple.
(Rires)
Une discussion récurrente que j'ai avec les éditeurs de magazines,
qui sont généralement des gens de lettres,
c'est que leur lectorat, vous,
est bien meilleur pour faire des connexions radicales avec des images
que ce que l'on croit.
S’il y a bien une chose qui me frustre, c'est qu'ils me poussent souvent
à avoir recours à une petite collection de clichés visuels vraiment éculés
mais considérés sans risque.
Vous savez, l'homme d'affaires qui grimpe une échelle,
puis l'échelle bouge et se transforme en graphique du marché boursier,
ou n'importe quoi avec le symbole dollar ; c'est toujours bon.
(Rires)
S'il y a des décideurs éditoriaux parmi vous aujourd'hui,
j'aimerais vous donner un conseil.
Chaque fois qu'un dessin comme celui-ci est publié,
un bébé panda mourra.
(Rires)
Littéralement.
(Applaudissements)
Quand est-ce qu'un cliché visuel est bon ou mauvais ?
L'équilibre est fragile.
Et ça dépend vraiment du fil narratif.
En 2011, au moment du tremblement de terre et du tsunami au Japon,
je réfléchissais à une couverture.
Je passais en revue les symboles classiques :
le drapeau japonais,
« La Grande Vague » de Hokusai, un des plus merveilleux dessins.
Et puis le fil narratif a changé :
la situation à la centrale électrique de Fukushima est devenue incontrôlable.
Je me souviens des images à la télé des travailleurs en combinaison Hazmat
qui marchaient à travers le site.
J'ai été frappé par le calme et la sérénité de la scène.
J'ai donc voulu créer une illustration d'une catastrophe silencieuse.
Et voilà l'image que j'ai créée.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Mon objectif est de susciter un moment de révélation chez le lecteur.
Malheureusement, cela ne veut pas dire
que j'ai ces révélations quand je crée mes images.
Je ne suis jamais assis à mon bureau
avec l'ampoule proverbiale qui se déclenche au-dessus de ma tête.
Ça exige en fait un processus très lent,
pas sexy du tout, de décisions de conception minimale,
qui, quand j'ai de la chance, me mène à une bonne idée.
Un jour, je suis dans le train, et j'essaie de déchiffrer
les règles graphiques pour les gouttes d'eau sur la fenêtre.
Finalement, je me suis rendu compte que,
« Ah, c'est l'arrière-plan qui est flou mais à l'envers,
contenu dans une image nette. »
Et je pensais, waouh, c'est vraiment cool ça,
mais qu'est-ce que je vais bien pouvoir faire de cette idée ?
Un peu plus tard, de retour à New York,
je dessine une image sur l'effet d'être dans un bouchon sur le pont de Brooklyn.
C'est vraiment agaçant, tout étant un peu poétique.
Et c'est plus tard que je me suis aperçu
que je peux prendre ces deux idées et les superposer en une seule image.
Je ne cherche pas à montrer une scène réaliste.
Mais, un peu comme de la poésie,
elle vous fait prendre conscience que vous aviez cette image en vous,
et que je n'ai fait que l'évoquer,
et vous pousser à réaliser qu'elle faisait partie de vous depuis tout ce temps.
Mais, comme la poésie, c'est un processus très délicat
qui n'est ni efficace ni modulable, je suppose.
Sans doute que la compétence la plus importante pour un artiste,
c'est vraiment l'empathie.
Vous avez besoin de votre art et de --
(Rires)
et vous avez besoin de créativité --
merci --
pour imaginer une image comme cela.
Mais ensuite, il faut prendre du recul
et regarder votre travail du point de vue du lecteur.
J'essaie de devenir un artiste meilleur en devenant un meilleur observateur.
Pour cela, j'ai commencé à faire un exercice
que j'appelle « dessiner le dimanche ».
C'est-à-dire que le dimanche, je prends un objet au hasard dans la maison
et j'essaie de voir si cet objet va déclencher une idée
qui n'a rien à voir avec l'usage original de celui-ci.
Souvent, ça veut dire que je reste devant une page blanche un certain temps.
Finalement l'astuce qui marche, c'est ouvrir mon esprit,
et passer en revue chaque image que j'ai entreposée,
et voir si ça déclenche quelque chose.
Si c'est le cas, j'ajoute quelques lignes d'encre pour connecter --
pour préserver ce très court moment d'inspiration.
C'est ça, la morale de l'histoire :
la vraie magie n'a pas lieu sur papier.
Elle a lieu dans l'esprit du spectateur.
Quand vos attentes et vos connaissances télescopent mes intentions artistiques.
Votre interaction avec une image,
votre capacité à la lire, à douter, à être dérangé, ennuyé ou inspiré
par une image
est aussi importante que ma contribution artistique.
Car c'est exactement ça qui transforme un acte artistique
en un véritable dialogue créatif.
Par conséquent, votre compétence pour lire les images
n'est pas uniquement impressionnante,
mais c'est elle qui rend mon art possible.
Et pour cela, je vous remercie beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
(Acclamations)
Merci.
(Applaudissements)